I didn't know if I was ready and I said
I'm not Colton in tears on Mondays
bachelor in paradise
the former football star was calm when
he and Tia decided to go their separate
ways I feel like I owe it to myself to
explore and figure out what I want with
other people too but the next day it was
a different story
Colton was forced to face his true
feelings after a surprise visit from
former Bachelorette Becca them rank of
sight
it wasn't true I was gonna happen I mean
everybody
if I was okay and I said yeah of course
I'm good I'm supposed to have the
perfect
everything
at least that's what I want to portray I
can't it's just falling apart
Colton hinted that seeing Becca made him
realize maybe he's not cut out for
paradise after all the tipping point I'm
not I can't be here I thought I was
strong enough to come here and move on
et spoke with Colton in July when he
dished on the emotional experience
something's happened that I wasn't
expecting to happen it was very
emotional
because I think you know I'm just coming
out of a relationship with Becca and I'm
dealing with Tia at the same time and
I'm also on a beach with a bunch of
beautiful women and some of my friends
so I wasn't expecting to feel the
emotions that I felt
[Music]